you know i i had a conversation with
someone from vice and the general idea
was they were like if you leave
you lose the cool factor oh no
but but no but think about it and the
cool factor when vice floor
it was a springboard for a lot of people
right for sure for sure like yeah
definitely lost that but at the time it
was a rule factor
now it is now it's now it's cringe
factor yeah so
at the time it was like if you stay here
and you do more of these videos because
like i did a video with kim.com the the
hacker dude
got it yeah and it got like for sure it
got like five million views overnight
and so vice was was hot on social media
and youtube and it was like if you leave
you're not gonna get this kind of
recognition
yeah you'll make more money and that's
they're really selling that eh that's
their whole thing
and you know what i said was i was like
dude those videos that got all those
views
that's me getting those views not you
yeah yeah and so
you know because i had already gotten a
ton of views on a ton of content but
they were really
you know going for that so i ended up
leaving this company and
here's the point of the story i got no
problem saying here's what all these
companies did i'll say it straight up
yeah
we need more people to do that like the
things you're mentioning about these
these tech companies how they sell ads
the fake game they play
the marketing companies that are telling
people to get woke and then it results
in trash content nobody wants
but the point is making before about how
it's kind of like an anchor is that
once you get woke you don't go back no
you can't because the culture's too
ingrained you know it's like
again once once you've you basically
tell everyone hey if we do something
else we're racist everyone's like got it
and then you come back you're like hey
we're gonna do something else and
they're like but that's racist
yeah and then nobody won't move but you
know you know what it's like uh you ever
see that uh
you ever hear that experiment they did
with like the chimps and they put them
in this room had sex with them all
yeah yeah and everyone got diseased no
they they they put a a ladder me and my
boys i don't know exactly how they did
it but here it's like an urban legend i
think i'm pretty sure it's a true story
they put like a the stool in the room
and they put fruit on top and then a
bunch of chimps and anytime a chimp
would try and climb the ladder get the
fruit they'd spray in with the hose
yeah so then eventually they all started
if any chimp tried to get the food
they'd the other day
beat the other chimp out yeah then one
by one they said
theories you know well but so one by one
they would switch the chimp out
then they'd put in a new channel yes and
they got rid of the hose there's a bunch
there's
different versions of that experiment
i've actually seen a different one but i
know exactly what you're talking about
and eventually no one knows why they're
doing it exactly so here's what happens
you get some guy at a tech company i'm
sorry at a media company
and they're sitting there scratching
their beard you know then and their man
bun and they're like
getting the vice tattoo on their neck
and while they're sitting there they're
going to
they're thinking themselves like how can
we boost views they're like let's try
some like woke feminist stuff
yeah they do it they get some marginal
boost from like shock content it's rage
bait
this guy gets a promotion and leaves he
gets replaced by a new
guy and now you have a whole room full
of woke people have no idea why they're
doing it
yeah and they'll never give it up it's
just becomes a genre
you know right you're trying to keep it
always happens in the comedy too it's
like
the thing that you're making fun of
becomes obsolete but they
the thing like for example you know if
you were talking about
you know the cop shows that are like hey
riggs you know
we're gonna do uh whatever right i'm
gonna do whatever what what
are they gonna do i was thinking you
know i'll say this first because it was
making me laugh
in my head the idea of you retired from
vice
and then vice being like can you come
back to an article and you're like you
know i don't do that anymore
i don't do it anymore shane one last job
one last job there's crack smokers in
russia
i'm sitting here and i'm like no and
then they like open a briefcase
and it's a bunch of secondary it's a
bunch of rings second second right
yeah yeah it's just a ring it's and and
look i think yeah yeah i couldn't get
through my point because i was making
myself
but it's just it's a briefcase with one
ring yeah and you're like
all right one last job get me my plaid
shirt
with rolled up sleeves and then it's
like the it's writing an article and
it's like the uh the crack addicted
coal miners of siberia and they're like
why can't someone else do it they're
like they can't talk to the crack
addicted coal miners
it's only you that have the skills to
infiltrate do you think you're telling
me a joke
let me tell you a story one of the
things that i got pitched
when i was there was a story about in
south south american mountains where the
men have to climb up
and like do mining unlike mountaintops
or whatever
yeah the women can't survive up there as
long as the men can because uh
typical absolutely well so this is what
i was told
that the women have a harder time
surviving because of the thin air
yeah so the men work up there for really
long periods of time
but they get lonely and because women
can't come up
other men have to dress up like women
and service the other men
and that was literally a vice story and
i was asked like would you want to go to
these mountains and like
interview this and they do a video i'm
like that sounds like yeah girls putting
a wig on and jerking off dudes
dudes doing putting wigs on dude yeah we
are not family friendly anymore
this sounds like the south park no it
wasn't that was like when's the plane
leave i was like
a parachute in land me on top of the
mountain yeah you come in you land on
the
like on the first give me my wig
servicing the guy
oh no too close for comfort you ever
seen the south park episode where the
the cops taking down the uh the uh the
john's by pretending to be a better oh
getting up
that's you you dress up like the wig he
gets married to the pimp yeah
he's like 10 years later you're doing
your six guys in but you have a gopro on
your head
no no no no oh my dude
you'd be surprised like when i was in
when i was in venezuela
yeah you have to work undercover for
seven months
i almost went to prison really i was in
venezuela
i had some high-profile venezuelan dude
accuse me of being a spy
all of a sudden i'm getting attacked
online like 10 000 tweets in a few
minutes
saying like we're coming for you you
know we're going to find you things from
people in venezuela yeah
while i was in venezuela how did they
see in the first place so i had posted
something on instagram
okay i was like it's no big deal i was
like i took a picture of the protest or
whatever and uploaded it and then some
high proof
and they could tell that you were like a
journalist yeah that's what they mean by
spy like they're like you're here
no they straight up said i was a spy
they said i was working for the cia okay
so they
so they were yeah okay so it was
actually american leftists started
tweeting at the guy saying tim poole
works for the cia
and he's in your country and so the dude
saw it went on his show and he started
showing pictures of me and he was like
look he's here he's here
and i started showing pictures of
corpses in ukraine claiming like i had
killed them or something like
crazy great stuff and so
what was that what i was told from vice
was can you make this the story
and i was like can you can you send me a
helicopter please so i would i
the first thing i did as soon as it
happened i was like airport airport
airport yeah
talk to security and they were like it
was the middle of the night you got to
wait till the sun cracks because you
don't want to get
killed sun cracked got in the cab got to
the airport got on that plane
and like i was sitting outside the gate
waiting for for boarding
and that's what i was asked by the guy's
advice they were like why don't you just
you know
this is the story and i was like they're
going to throw me in prison dude
yeah yeah i called i called my family
and you're like they're like sick right
they're like well you'll be fine and i
talk to my family how many articles you
could write from prison dude seriously
no you won't you
you wouldn't write any but then like so
i was talking about that i murdered a
guy and did 15 years in prison
that that probably is i'm sure it is a
big long piece no but uh i was talking
to some family members and they said
well if you go to prison you're probably
in for a couple you'll be in for a
couple years
but uh the state department eventually
will eventually get you out and then you
can write a book about it
prison in there in venezuela every
everyone you talk to is like dude this
can be great for your career you're like
can someone get me out of here well
does anyone care your lawyers like
you're like hey okay so i need a lawyer
right now he's like let me ask you a
question have you started writing what
kind of
are you using your laptop now what kind
of percentage can we talk about after
two years no no lawyers think you're
calling him and negotiate the book deal
the point the point i was bringing up
with my family member was not that they
were encouraging me to go to prison was
there like that's the mentality of what
they're thinking yeah
they want you to stay because then they
could have this international entire our
journalist was there he was totally on
the on the level
i'm not saying that's actually what they
wanted you know vice necessarily yeah
but that's what my family member thought
they were going for like some people
people in my family were just like
it sounds like and so i was like i'm
gonna be on that plane and i remember
sitting on that plane and i was just
like sweating bullets waiting and then
as soon as the wheels
lifted off the ground i was like yes
when i got back
one of the intern's advice was
venezuelan was he rampant to me like how
did you get out
i was like what do you mean he's like
how did you get out
and that was just like i went to the
airport and playing up there like wow
because they throw people in prison for
way less than what they accused you of
being an american spy yeah and then
somebody hacked my
my family's accounts phones they hacked
my my facebook account
like dude this is the craziest thing a
friend of mine i talked to in like six
years
uh messaged me saying you need to call
me immediately the fbi is asking about
you
and i was like this is probably like
something to do with what happened
so i mail body inspectors i call him and
he doesn't answer
i call him several times he doesn't
answer finally he calls me back like
four hours later and he's like
why are you calling me dude and i was
like you told me to call you he was like
we're talking i haven't talked to you in
like four or five years bro
and i was like i got a message from you
on facebook saying call you and he was
like
dude i didn't message you i haven't
talked to you in years i sent him a
screenshot of it and he was like bro i
never messaged you
and so i talked to some of my cyber
security friends and they said it was a
uh
i want cyber security friends messaging
in a messaging injection attack
what they think happened was that the
venezuelan cyber security infrastructure
was trying to get me to make a phone
call from inside the country so they
could find out where i was
but wow but i was back in the states so
when i called them it didn't do anything
and then because uh because i'm a funny
guy i use the gps
i use the gps spoofer and then i tweeted
something like
these arepas are delicious and then i
made my gps location
venezuela really i was like there you go
guys
you outsmarted them no i don't think i
actually did anything you know i have no
idea
but uh but they did hack they did hack
all all of my stuff
uh my facebook you know there was there
was like an unknown log and stuff and so
that's that's freaky
i've had a few of those dude i had a guy
that said sent me he's like this is your
uh
pass this was like a month ago and it
was like i've got your password and i've
been watching you through your webcam or
whatever and you need to someone did
that to you yeah
it was like a month ago but i it was in
my spam and i was looking for another
email so i saw my spam and it's like
it's
a month ago but he had my password right
wow and i was like
yeah but you know i don't know man
sometimes people
i don't know it's weird like what's he
going to get from you i don't know i'm
sure if yeah there's
someone stupid or would have been like i
don't know here's two thousand dollars
whatever it is like yeah yeah some rich
dude they're like hey we're gonna
send all your like in i mean to be fair
if someone was in
my group chats right now and was like
hey we just like
i just have a transcript of all your
group chats and i'm going to release
them all i'd be like
here's my house uh would you like to
have sex with my girlfriend
like i mean just you give me the list of
demands
here's my mom whatever you need because
this cannot get out
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you